not everybody works with forun 500
company many people they might work by
small and medium businesses the thing is
the small business owners are really
tough to know fault of your own they can
cancel because they just can't make
payroll that month the biggest model
that I've seen for small business owners
from a marketing perspective was an
agency that was running $300 a month
they had completely automated every
aspect of it I think it generated
reviews and maybe a couple phone calls a
month but at a $300 a month price point
if they got one or two phone calls a
month it was worth it so the bar to get
over to ascribe value and especially on
something that I call like a nuisance
business for $2 or $300 a month I don't
feel guilty about not doing it because
this is being handled